we need to recognize that when it comes
to the economic gap between blacks and
whites in America it does come from a
great injustice that has never been
dealt with that great injustice has had
to do with the fact that there was 250
years of slavery followed by another
hundred hundred years of domestic
terrorism what makes me qualified to say
200 to 500 billion dollars I'll tell you
what makes me qualified if you did the
math of the 40 acres and a mule given
that there was four to five million
slaves at the end of the Civil War
don't fortify and they were all probably
40 acres and a mule for every family of
four if you did the math today it would
be trillions of dollars and I believe
that anything less than 100 billion
dollars is is an insult and I believe
that 200 to 500 billion is is
politically feasible today because so
many Americans realize there is an
injustice that continues to form a
toxicity underneath the surface and
emotional turbulence that's it thank you
very much senator